can't even believe this story I heard
about with Whitney that is it true you
heard it on the radio for the first time
I did I was coming home from my office
uh from downtown on music road to my
home in Brentwood and I was driving at
the time I had my
Cadillac it just like a dog you know
hearing a a whistle I was saying what
you know it's like it was ringing some
sort of a bell but it didn't it didn't
dawn on me by the time I realized it she
was ready to go into the course and then
when she started that I I almost wrecked
honest to God had to pull over to the
side at a
Walgreens uh you know there in Brentwood
or where the Walgreens is now and to
listen to the rest of it and it was the
most
overwhelming sensation because I
couldn't believe my little country's sad
song you know could even be done like
that but to hear it like that and it was
just overwhelming that was one of the
greatest uh experiences I've ever had in
my entire life